and here's another thing too though you
know we always talk about climate change
we talk about the issues we're
destroying the planet we know that we're
making the weather worse we've got this
god-awful bomb cyclone happening right
now
which has essentially formed what could
be called a cold-weather hurricane over
dry land in the middle of America 100
mile an hour winds but climate change is
only a small part I can't say small part
it's at least half the picture don't get
me wrong but it's half the picture
there's another half of the picture
about pollution that we're not talking
about enough either and that is the fact
that just pollution alone not even
factoring in the extreme weather from
climate change but the pollution alone
is killing people in fact for the most
recent years that numbers are available
which I believe is 2015 8 point 8
million people around the globe died
just from air pollution air pollution
alone killed eight point eight million
human beings in a single year
air pollution now kills more people a
year than smoking so that that horrible
thing that we've known for decades kills
people smoking gives you cancer tobacco
industry covered it up that doesn't even
hold a candle anymore to how many people
are dying from air pollution so I bring
this up to bring up this when you hear
people saying we can't afford to address
climate change or even worse climate
changes a hoax
we shouldn't make the planet better
because climate change isn't real
ok you're wrong but let's assume for a
second you end up being right and
climate change was a big hoax the eight
point eight million people who die each
year from air pollution that's not a
hoax the people who develop cancer from
the corporate toxins that get dumped
into bodies of water in the Ohio River
Valley like what happened with C 8
that's not a hoax
even if climate change weren't real we
would
be better off we would be healthier and
we would have fewer deaths if we stop
the pollution so that alone that alone
should be enough to make this happen I
don't understand how there are still
arguments against it except I do
understand because just like with
corporate media it's that corporate
money flow into politicians creating
these phony little think tanks that put
out their phony little papers and they
pay scientists to put their names on
them to say climate change isn't real
it's all funded by the fossil fuel
industry all of it they actually have a
listserv by the way we've seen this in
in Discovery for court cases against
some of these major companies they have
a list serve of scientists and academics
at colleges that they use to pay them a
lot of money and then they just sign off
on whatever nonsense report that these
chemical and fossil fuel companies want
to put out saying that their product is
safe saying that it doesn't cause cancer
saying that it won't destroy the
environment that exists it's disgusting
it's shameful but there are plenty of
people in this country who will do
anything for a buck and unfortunately
that does not always exclude those in
the scientific community but all of this
again we got to have the message of hope
and there is hope and the hope is coming
from the younger generation tomorrow
March 15th 2019 across this country
there's going to be a massive strike of
schoolchildren here in the United States
what are they striking they're striking
against government in action on the
issue of climate change the hope for
this planet not just for this country
before this planet lies with that
generation they're the ones more so than
any of us who are one gonna deal with
the most extreme effects of climate
change and to have dealt with it for
their entire lives even me and I'm a
millennial
I'm on the upper edge of the millenials
but I'm still a millennial when I was a
kid yeah we knew the term greenhouse
effect we knew the term global warming
but it wasn't a big deal we weren't
experiencing the effects of it the kids
in high school middle school today this
is all they've ever known for their
entire lives you've had the 97%
consensus about climate change they have
seen they you know we're in their
formative years when we had these
massive catastrophes Hurricane Ivan
Hurricane Katrina hurricane Maria
hurricane Irma hurricane Michael
hurricane Harvey the California
wildfires the California droughts fires
in Colorado these bomb cyclones this is
their life and they want us to do
something now because they're not old
enough to run for office so that they
can do something and we owe it to them
until they hit that age where they can
run for office and do some good in this
country it's up to us to protect it for
them because they're taking this issue
seriously because they know they've got
to deal with the consequences we'll be
right back